[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction de tv
fil 78 l'essentiel de l'actualité
yvelinoise voici les titres en images de
ce 26 janvier dernier débat de la belle
alliance hier soir benoît hamon est il
d'ores et déjà le grand vainqueur de
cette primaire nous étions avec ses
sympathisants pour suivre les derniers
échanges de leurs favoris avec manuel
valls et dernier volet de notre dossier
consacré ce mois ci au profession
méconnue aujourd'hui en rencontre avec
l'un des derniers garnisseur de pied de
marteau de piano et puis en fin de
journal vous entendrez georges schmit
mai à alger d'une famille de musiciens
originaires d'alsace cet artiste aux
multiples talents est un virtuose vous
l'avez vu de la flûte de pan
trois entreprises de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines figurent dans
le top 100 mondial est des entreprises
les plus innovantes au monde cette
information économique pour débuter on
compte parmi ses entreprises safran est
spécialisé dans l'aéronautique la
défense la sécurité située à magny les
hameaux
thales également à elancourt autre géant
de l'aérospatial et de la défense et
enfin valeo équipementier automobile
basé à la verrière un classement élaboré
à partir du nombre de brevets déposés
durant les cinq dernières années et de
leur niveau de mondialisation a mais
aussi de la qualité et de l'innovation
en politique
j moins 3 avant le second tour de la
primaire de la gauche manuel valls
benoît hamon entamer la dernière ligne
droite décisive avec le débat de
l'entre-deux-tours attrape lé soutien du
favori benoît hamon s'était réuni pour
cette soirée forcément spécial le
reportage de nicolas kirillovitch ce
sont des signes qui ne trompent pas les
petits fours des visages tendus et une
ambiance sérieuse attrape ils étaient
une quarantaine à s'être réunis pour
suivre le débat entre leur champion et
manuel valls
finalement ils ont assisté à un duel
cordiale économie laïcité sécurité ou
encore environnement ont permis aux
finalistes d'exposer leur vision de la
gauche il nous
tolérer ou nous de nos infos que nos
modes de production et nos modes de
consommation mettent en péril
mais alors qui sort vainqueur du débat
voilà le réel enjeu de cette soirée dans
le fief électoral du député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines et il n'y
avait qu'un vainqueur et par ko nouvelle
fois on a parlé de ses propositions
parce qu'ils aient travaillé avec
sérieux depuis de longs mois
il est pas con idée depuis le mois
décembre connu et le bâti et depuis le
mois de doute ou de juillet oui un vrai
clivage mais entre un projet qui quelque
part ressasse des idées et des mots d'un
système à bout de souffle et puis bah
est un projet qui pense le monde de
demain
reste à savoir désormais si ce clivage
et ces différences pourront être
dépassés le soir du dimanche 29 janvier
la question du rassemblement est en
effet moins évidente chez les militants
de benoît hamon
si c'est vrai ce ligue en battant mieux
pour lui mais je pense que benoît hamon
donc avec les années il se présentera
peut-être à la présidentielle pour repas
benoît hamon le meilleur candidat à la
fois pourra pour rassembler la gauche et
les sympathisants socialistes mais
rassemblée après après cette primaire
rassembler l'ensemble de la gauche
il est capable de parler aussi bien jean
luc mélenchon cas pierre laurent ou
yannick jadot et à tous les électeurs de
gauche
nouvelle étape ce soir avant le résultat
des urnes les deux candidats sont en
meeting en ile-de-france manuel valls à
alfortville et benoît hamon à montreuil
nous poursuivrons dans ce journal notre
série de reportages débuté lundi sur les
professions méconnu aujourd'hui
direction la verrière pour découvrir une
activité unique en france
le garnissage de marteau de piano le
reportage est signée nicolas landry le
feutre est au piano ce que le pneu est à
la voiture patrick des fougères et
garnisseur de marteau le seul en france
avec un savoir-faire très spécifique
transmis depuis 1925 un feu peut
résister 30 ans pour des particuliers et
5 ans pour des professionnels suivants
comme on joue comme les pneumatiques
comment
oui donc abandonné le feu tu es trop dur
ou trop mou ou la son il est mort
vers la structure interne du feutre et
est morte
donc faut le regarder et tout ça se fait
à la main ont dégarni et ont regardé un
feutre ça dure on va dégarnir un ancien
fait pour garder avec nous vos photos
comme son père avant lui patrick reprend
la sphère familiale dans les années 90
il s'installe à la verrière en 2007 avec
ses deux salariés en position de
monopole sur le marché européen il
s'exporte aussi en russie aux etats-unis
ou en australie
avec un réseau de près de 1000 clients
il ya des gens qu'on va revoir souvent
d'autres qu'on va voir une fois tous les
ans pour tous les dix ans il ya des
nouveaux qui arrivent c'est un marché de
collectionneurs de passionnés faut
savoir que j'ai des concurrents mais qui
font dans l'industrie lourde arctique
qui créent et qui fabrique des têtes 9
pour la première manche où la seconde
monde et piano moderne donc toujours
petit marché en petite niche mais vu
qu'on est salée certain savoir faire on
est clairement unique donc bah ça ça
fait dix quand même l'entreprise
un vrai boulot c'est un regard ni soeur
de marteau de piano pour les périodes 20
30 et aussi avant les pianos pas piano
carré est forte et piano
des canaux très anciens grâce à leur
technicité les ateliers des fougères ont
obtenu le label d'état entreprise du
patrimoine vivant
on en reste traditionnelle dans notre
savoir faire par contre ça de choses
modernes pour pour améliorer vos tant au
niveau qualité ou vos tensions par des
fautes mais faute d'attention donc un
mandat une certaine tension ça se fait
que la machine
donc on reçoit des jeunes partout comme
ça ça fait tout un jeu de marteau ont
dégarni à la main ou à la vapeur là dans
ce cas là c'est à la main on va mettre
tout ce jeu là qui est devant moi sauce
au porto marteau et décale avec des crs
bien précise des gabarits alors mais la
bande là le jeu de marteau dans son
porte marteau ici et ça va descendre ici
oui il possède ses petits secrets de
production et forme lui même sa main
d'oeuvre
patrick serait le dernier des des
fougères à exercer cette activité
ces enfants ne s'étant pas accordé à la
voix artisanale théâtre à présent un
univers et glacial au pays des inuits et
une route vers le grand nord c'est ce
que propose la compagnie l'unijambiste
avec le spectacle in eu qu un voyage
sous la neige
du 25 au 28 janvier au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour les
petits et pour les grands comme le veut
la formule consacrée
une réflexion sur le monde racontée de
façon ludique avec être des animaux et
qui prennent vie à humaniser comme
l'expliquent le metteur en scène david
gauchard donc je vais aller voir les
inuits du nunavik qui en fait est une
région
québécoise ou là bas ils sont
francophones il étudie encore la langue
française donc ça c'était important pour
moi aussi de retracer ce chemin là et
donc je suis parti dans un village qui
s'appelle kandji sud jacques qui est un
tout petit village avec le beatboxer l
os photographe dan ramène et le rappeur
armes
j'ai interrogé après l'équipe technique
et
les comédiens pour partir sur un
spectacle il y aurait très peu de textes
presque documentaire et poétique
vous allez trouver cet équilibre en
partant sur des simples mots et faisant
des improvisations
comment on fait la banquise comment on
fait le blizzard voilà c'était petites
choses comme ça et donc sur scène je
tenais à ce que le spectacle soit comme
un carnet de voyage culture toujours la
salle d'exposition de guyancourt ouvre
ses portes sur l'exposition banlieue
banlieue les pionniers de l'art urbain
français vous invite à un voyage dans le
temps le collectif d'artistes banlieue
banlieue a été créée dans les années 80
il peignait alors des tableaux des
fresques collectives
ils se retrouvent trente ans plus tard
et jusqu'au 16 avril vous pourrez donc
traversé la salle des expositions aller
à la découverte d'une cinquantaine
d'oeuvres on écoute l'un des membres de
ce collectif c'est au micro de camille
lambert à l'initiative de jeunes
trentenaires qui s'occupe de cette salle
d'exposition
on vient chercher des 50 mais avoir d
exagérées qui continue à peindre qui
sont plus forcément dans la rue qui sont
plus forcément sur les murs extérieurs
et on leur propose
montrez ce travail de l'époque alors ici
on voit des toiles donc finalement c'est
une expo un peu plus classique mais
c'est un reflet c'est comme un peu des
extraits de ce qu'on pouvait mettre dans
la rue alors que se profile le festival
d'angoulême et que se poursuit le
festival bubble ce qui donc à saint
quentin en yvelines un atelier de
création de bd est organisée dans les
différentes médiathèques de
l'agglomération
le dessinateur kara anime ses activités
avec des jeunes qui sont venus
participer
le reportage de nicolas landry ophélie
s'endort et commence à rêver voyage dans
l'époque des dinosaures virée dans le
future transformation en sirène une
histoire dessinée par carat à partir des
idées proposées par des jeunes place à
la création de la vème planche
j'ai eu l'idée que la baleine
voilà à la fin se transforme en
grenouille et quelques cars advienne
guerrière amazon il faut que
graphiquement je trouve des astuces pour
aller plus vite même s'il ya du décor
même s'il ya plusieurs personnages donc
pendant que moi je dessine e dessine
aussi de leur côté je leur fils parfois
quelques petits conseils à droite à
gauche pour que je puisse un petit peu
aussi s'amuser de leur côté depuis une
quinzaine d'années car a écrit des bd
bercé par des influences franco belge et
le style manga dans cet atelier il donne
des conseils aux jeunes présents
le dessin autour et plus du style bd et
que en fait le visage de la jeune fille
est plus difficilement gras j'aime
vraiment beaucoup le mongol pichichi ça
me plaisait vraiment contrairement aux
autres dessins animés qui passe à la
télé il dû signer au genoa or pour le
réseau des médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'objectif est
de rendre ce moment participatif avec
l'encadrement d'un professionnel
d'autres animations sont prévues dans le
cadre du festival bubble sky jusqu'au 18
février prochain de la musique pour
terminer cette édition du journal avec
georges schmit c'est un spécialiste de
la flûte de pan il était en concert le
week-end dernier à prestation dimanche à
rambouillet avec un organiste également
camille lambert
[Musique]
un dialogue entre flûte de pan et orgue
sur un opéra d'haendel au coeur de
l'église sainte bernadette de
rambouillet un cadre exceptionnel pour
un duo complémentaire la flûte de pan
c'est l'ancêtre de l'orgue c'est un grec
qui s'appelait et aitziber ross qui a eu
l'idée de réaliser une flûte de temps
beaucoup plus grande que l'on appelle
depuis à l'orgue
mais c'est depuis l'antiquité donc entre
les flûtes de pan partout à travers le
monde se sont forcément deux instruments
qui se marient très bien puisqu'il ils
vivent sur le même la même énergie à
savoir l'air l'air qui nous fait tous
vivre de jean sébastien bach à erik
satie en passant par la musique
traditionnelle irlandaise
le concert a traversé les époques rate
un laps de temps à travers le folklore
d'amérique du sud ou d'europe centrale
moi j'ai décidé à il ya très longtemps
de cela les dépoussiérer un petit peu
cet instrument qui millénaire en
adaptant justement de la musique
classique en proposant même musique
il ya beaucoup de choses qui se
concentre tout un talent tout une
approche de la musique qui nous livre
aussi à travers le concert voilà c'est
s'est réincarné sa façon de faire de la
musique durant l'année 2010 est georges
schmitt sera en tournée dans différentes
églises et cathédrales de france
il sera à chaque fois compagnie de
différents musiciens
c'est la fin de ce journal
rendez vous lundi pour une nouvelle
édition nous vous ferons bien évidemment
un point complet sur les résultats du
second tour de cette primaire de la
gauche demain vendredi aux horaires
habituels nicolas qui rit le vide c'est
son invité pour commenter l'actualité de
la semaine écoulée très belle soirée
[Musique]